[musique]
Eh bien, en plus, nous résolvons le problème principal
pour notre pays dans son ensemble en fournissant
les matières premières nécessaires à l'approvisionnement
la sécurité et c'est un tour d'horizon clé
[musique]
bien, comment comprenez-vous
faire ce qui se passe dans notre pays
touche la chair de tout le monde et tout le monde a
amis connaissances qui sont à Turin et au moins
impliqué dans la défense et la défense du pays
de toute façon ça ne regarde personne
[musique]
Eh bien, bien sûr, le garçon s'inquiète aussi
le début de la guerre et pour les familles pour les leurs
notre option, qui est la [ __ ] de merde
chacun se dit à sa place, mais aussi par cela
pas moins nous âme avec eux crêpe et rôle
quelqu'un doit donner
[musique]